the gyro can experience there was one
story that I was reading about where
these [ __ ] guys were working during
construction in Maine and they rented a
house and the neighbors had decided that
these people might have the corona and
so they've been there since September
they had they been in the [ __ ] town
since September working on a
construction site say they chopped a
tree down and blocked their [ __ ]
driveway and threatened them with guns
they they have to quarantine them
they're forcing them to quarantine look
at this group of local vigilantes tried
to forcibly quarantine out-of-towners
that's Maine for you that's [ __ ]
that's Maine for you dude Maine is a
strange place it's a strange place
you ain't never seen drunk good you
never seen drunk tea seen like a bar in
Bangor
those people could throw down and
they're all in that you know they're in
that brutal brutal brutal cold brutal
cold for a long time they went to the
mainland were targeted because of
license plate when they arrived back in
vin owl haven Vanille Haven an exchange
between roommates and some local
residents apparently didn't go well she
said adding that a group of local
vigilantes decided to take matters into
their own hands and barricade these guys
into their rental property mrs.
MacDonald called the commotion a
tremendous waste of resources noting
that he had drawn a response from
several officials so silly but that's
Maine there's a lot of dummies up there
a lot of nice people don't get me wrong
but you know there's log dummies up
there they call maniacs and they get
real mad if you make me guys screaming
at me I was telling Maine jokes in Maine
and he would scream and he would stand
it up and he was an old dude too
pointing at me screaming like he really
identified with Maine and I was trying
to understand I go I go do you identify
with Maine do you think I'm talking
about you what's going on here man why
men I was making fun of the number of
people that were shot by deer in Maine a
shot idea or shot hunting and mistaken
for a deer
sorry shot by a deer that's hilarious
and I was making this joke about it like
I mean how many [ __ ] people live here
and this guy got up I [ __ ] knew her
Sakura screaming at me and I was like
whoa buddy these are just jokes
it doesn't make this a lot better but
this thing and man it's a severe it's a
small island town Oh even worse they're
[ __ ] trying to key that that's why
they're saying get back to the mainland
I was like why are they saying mainland
cuz they think if someone came over
there with the booty
yeah but those guys have been there
since September these people are just
idiots
[Laughter]
[Applause]